joel here we go love your honest take on
things i mean we hung on your every word
for how many years with the soup
as well as your multiple you know
television shows and movies but
we like to hear your honest opinion so
if you're open to it we'd like to take
the joel paul
[Music]
everything is very disturbing about that
uh
that's my i should have called the joel
mchale show on netflix the joel paul
maybe it would still be on
that's terrifying all right well okay
comment on this how do you feel about
skinny jeans the kids say they're
out hey you kids
uh just so you know it skinny jeans will
never
be out until you pry them off my cold
dead very compressed calves
okay still in i've invested way too much
okay hugging was trending on twitter the
other day
are hugs gross now okay hugs have always
been
not gross and gross uh they've always
there's a spectrum of hug and if you let
the hug go even a
second or two too long then it's gross
yeah i i think it's time for just the
birth of a new salutation
okay it's the final season of keeping up
with the kardashians any predictions on
what we might
see in the final season is that a
television show
yes exactly
on your old alma mater e oh i always
called it
yeah hey i'm i'm so sorry for the
kardashians because you know i i can't
believe the show got canceled
um i thought it was gonna make i thought
it was gonna go the distance
yeah it's like 20 000 years i think it's
been on
early on we used to make fun of them on
the soup
and kris kardashian would call every
week
and be like he made fun of us again and
so it was then the president of e would
call ted harbor would be
it was like we had thrown a baseball
into their yard and then they're like
this is mine and uh and so
ted would always be like hey man can you
kind of lay off them this week
and i'll be like sure and it's like the
two weeks from now is fine
and so that it was and then i got to
know chris a little bit and she's lovely
and but i was that was early on that was
back in 2006 drew
i know so many people who know and work
with them and like
the rumors are just nice upon nice upon
nice
yeah and that i think that is their
secret weapon
for their longevity is that they're
super kind and their crew
i think their crew would die for them so
i think it's uh it's they they made that
thing a real family and
obviously the popularity uh was almost
as popular as the soup but still
they got close i love the soup
so much i never missed an episode it's
like the best show ever
and look i'm like a talk show house now
do you have any advice for me joel the
problem is
you're uh you've been on a short period
of time but you're really good
at it so which i mean obviously that is
that's the thing is that you've kept
this thing conversational
and kind of uh and very cool you're not
you're you're you can tell the vibe is
relaxed and so
uh you're cool and calm so that that
lends itself to professionalism which we
rarely went after that's that's uh
it's hard to pull a clip you know what i
think when we launched you probably
could have pulled a lot of clips
oh um well i came out of the time
machine
yeah i came out of the gate real real
strong i mean i was like hosting a talk
show with no
you know not a lot of guests and no
audience and i was like i know i'm just
gonna go for it and it was like
the third quarter of 2020 like we were
all nuts
it was it was a time it was a weird time
to come out
acting like everything was normal so i
just kind of
went with it and you think that when an
audience returns it will you'll be
like feel it's all of a sudden new again
like all of a sudden you're hosting a
different
type of show or do you think you'd be
like ah i've had so many
so many uh uh reps that i'll be fine
i think that you know the crew and i
really like bounce off each other and we
sort of made a pact early on to just
like be noisy
and ourselves and kind of egg each other
on because you do need that energy and i
would always hear people
giggling and you know egging you on on
the soup
it's like if you do this to avoid you're
gonna go crazy
because nobody can work without any
response
like when we were starting other than
our crew and family i had no idea if
anything was funny or landing
like that's what an audience can give
you is some barometer and indication so
thank god for the crew because they have
been that north star for me
and the energy in the room and so i'm
very lucky and i think other people will
just be
an extra addition to yeah no i think
you're i can hear your crew laughing and
that's really cool that's the thing
they don't give it up so if they do
laugh you know they like it
it's i we the first year of the soup
nobody watched so the only people
laughing were the crew
and the writers and the producers so
that when people started watching
i never change the mindset that i'm like
oh i'm still just trying to make my
friends laugh
and uh i think that i kept that
throughout the
12 years uh that we did it so and and
that really helped me
because i i didn't again i didn't know
if it was funny or not
i was constantly questioning it um i
think
that was the best piece of advice that
if we
do keep the intimacy of this show
and we're trying to make each other
laugh rather than like
pandering to the outside maybe that is a
secret recipe because the soup
was crushed it was like the first of its
kind
and i think there's been many copies uh
since and it's just you were such an
original
and it was a magical recipe so i'm
really going to take that advice to
heart and i will be happy
and we wanted to launch a show that we
were enjoying and
having a good time at and felt thankful
to be
at uh regardless so yeah i think we'll
keep that
that recipe joel thank you i just wish i
had made money off those other shows
but i didn't ah you gotta laugh
see hey yes so
mchale i'm so happy to see you and hang
out and thank you for that brilliant
advice
and i'm just so happy for your movie
happily which is so fun and delicious
and out in theaters and on demand right
now and
give my very best to your family